le lithium aussi appelé or blanc est
l'une des ressources les plus
recherchées dans la course à la
transition énergétique on le trouve dans
les batteries et notamment celle qui
équipe nos véhicules électriques avec
pour objectif la fin des voitures
thermiques en 2035 la demande en lithium
explose mais alors comment faire face où
trouvons-nous le lithium et comment
l'extraire
nous avons rendez-vous en banlieue
parisienne chez l'un des leaders du
marché français et Ramette leur
technique extraire en Argentine le
lithium contenu dans la saumure un
liquide se trouve en plusieurs
kilomètres sous terre face aux murs
c'est ça c'est de l'eau très très salée
10 fois plus salé que l'eau de mer et à
l'intérieur ben vous le voyez pas mais
il y a du lithium et donc le but du
travail des ramettes ça a été de trouver
un procédé pour extraire les capter le
lithium qui à l'intérieur de cette de
cette eau très salée et le transformer
en carbonate de lithium et le carbone
abitium c'est utilisé pour fabriquer des
batteries Lithium de vos voitures
électriques début 2022 et ramène
installe Sephora dans la province de
Salta en Argentine un projet à 345
millions d'euros le plus difficile n'est
pas de puiser la saumure mais d'élaborer
un procédé pour en extraire le lithium
on va la faire passer à travers des
colonnes et ces colonnes on va la
remplir avec une épaule à lithium donc
on a déposé des brevets là dessus et
c'était pour la lithium en fait elle va
capter le lithium qui a dans la saumure
ce lithium ensuite on va continuer à le
purifier le nettoyer on va le concentrer
et c'est cette poudre blanche qui va
être utilisée par les fabricants de
batterie lithium ici en Argentine
d'autres forages sont en cours de
construction l'objectif est de produire
à terme 24000 tonnes de lithium par an
soit l'équivalent de 500 000 batteries
de voiture mais ce n'est pas suffisant à
l'horizon 2040 c'est à dire dans 20 ans
c'est pas loin il nous faudra 40 fois
plus de lithium chaque année que ce
qu'on consomme aujourd'hui c'est énorme
je suis pas sûr qu'il y ait des on est
déjà connu dans l'histoire de l'humanité
une augmentation de besoin aussi rapide
et donc forcément ça veut dire que
derrière il faut qu'on mette en place
des nouvelles mines des nouvelles
exploitations des nouvelles usines aussi
de raffinage pour être capable de
produire ces
méthode ces batteries qui viendront
alimenter nos véhicules électriques et
nous permettront de décarboner les
transports qui jouent le rappel
représente bonhomme allant entre un
quart et un tiers de nos émissions de
CO2 annuelle on a fait des travaux un
peu plus prédictifs si vous voulez pour
essayer d'évaluer la probabilité qu'on
trouve du lithium en fonction de tout ce
qu'on sait de la géologie et ces travaux
nous ont montré qu'on est sans doute le
pays européen ou un des pays européens
on a le plus de chance de trouver de
lithium
ce qui a aujourd'hui nous consommions
peu de lithium principalement des piles
ou de petites batteries d'appareils
ménagers la totalité de nos besoins en
or blanc provient de l'étranger mais les
géants du secteur anticipent l'avenir en
multipliant leurs sources
d'approvisionnement et en les
rapprochant de la France
nous avons des équipes d'exploration de
géologues qui parcourent le monde à la
recherche des nouveaux gisements qui
permettront de continuer à produire du
lithium on parcourt le monde et parmi
les nombreux projets que nous avons nous
pouvons parler du projet en Alsace ou
nous projetons également de produire du
lithium à partir de source géothermales
mais ça reste un projet pour l'instant
qui est à l'étude mais réaliser un tel
projet en France n'est pas si simple
réglementation étude d'impact
acceptation sociale si Eramet réussi son
pari l'usine n’ouvrira pas ses portes
avant de nombreuses années et risquerait
même d'arriver derrière son plus gros
concurrent à Beauvoir dans l'Allier
Imerys vient d'annoncer l'ouverture
d'une mine géante de lithium en réalité
c'est en exploitant un gisement de
kaolin que les ingénieurs se sont
aperçus que les seuls étaient également
riches en lithium près d'un million de
Thunder Blanc serait enfouis dans ses
sols mais contrairement à la mine
[Musique]
alors que cette mine ne pourra être
opérationnelle avant 5 ans les prix du
lithium explosent aujourd'hui la tonne
se négocie 50000 euros contre 6400 en
[Musique]